the ronald mcdonald house in canada
has announced that it will evict all of
its tenants
adults and children over the age of five
who are not vaccinated by the end of
january
the ronald mcdonald house
is a great charity that houses kids and
their families while the kids receive
treatment at local hospitals
the father of a little boy
who is suffering from leukemia has just
responded to his eviction notice
this is an eviction notice i believe to
anybody older than five who's not
vaccinated is getting evicted from
ronald mcdonald house so i'm just gonna
go talk to people at the counter and see
if it's legit
like we got this last night yes
uh it's just pretty disturbing i'm just
wondering
is this saying that like everybody's not
fascinated
will we have a grace period to which you
can
get your first dose but essentially as
of january 17th it's a board mandate
from our uh
[Music]
so i just want to get this straight so
by the end of the month
my four-year-old boy leukemia is getting
evicted
because we don't have a vaccine
appearance this is if he was six months
old
but yeah because we don't have the
vaccine you're going to
throw us on the snow
with a few weeks notice
like this is some kind of crazy evil
like i have never seen in my life
this is evil this is extremely this is
one of the most evil things i've ever
seen
and there's the woman just following
orders just standing there in her mask
totally blank face i can't see most of
her face because of the stupid mask but
she's saying yes we're going to evict
you
and your
leukemia-ridden little boy
because
you won't take the experimental drug and
he and probably because he won't take
the experimental drug
to protect against a virus that poses
very very very little risk to him
even obviously leukemia is going to
greatly increase that risk
but the father has made a decision maybe
the boy's not going to get the shot in
order to
i don't know in consultation with the
doctor because it's not a good idea
because it's an experimental drug
because for whatever reason because they
won't make the
parents
who are already in this incredibly
difficult medical
moment are now being told sorry you're
out on the street
there's a scene that whitaker chambers
the ex-communist turned conservative
explains in
witness where he's walking down the
street with a fellow communist and
they're talking about how they've got to
improve the lot of the poor masses
and a beggar walks up to them and asks
for money
and whitaker chambers
reaches into his pocket to give him a
coin
and the communist next to me says don't
give him any money
don't give it to him
it's hard i know but do do not help that
man
it will dull the revolutionary spirit
you can't do it
and he saw the pain on the communist's
face and that whitaker chambers felt
this pain to do not give him money you
shouldn't give him money
it will it's better
it'll be better in the long run if you
don't have any charity
this is what people mean when they say
that the left
cares a lot about humanity but doesn't
care about actual humans
this is the difference between a vague
abstract humanitarianism
that's going to save the world and
improve the world versus charity
which is a good old christian virtue
it's theological virtue and charity is
when you care about your fellow man and
you actually do things to help your
fellow man charity is a lot harder than
humanitarianism
very very different concepts
leftist ideologues hate charity
what is charity
charity is just to use
a clear definition the infused
supernatural virtue by which a person
loves god above all things for his own
sake and loves others for the for god's
sake
charity is this virtue where we
recognize okay i love my god i'm
supposed to love my god with all my
heart and soul and man is made in the
image of god and god tells me to love
others as
as i love myself and i'm made in the
image of god okay
i'm going to love that i'm going to
treat this person
as someone who is bearing the very image
of god
which means that when you come across
that beggar on the street
you were talking to an eternal being
humanitarianism is different
humanitarianism
is
just kind of on the aggregate raising a
lot of people and if you got to kill a
few people in order to do that well
that's just what has to be done if you
need to crack a few omelette crack a few
omelets if you need to crack a few eggs
to make an omelet that's just the way
the recipe works
totally the opposite of charity
ah you know what to do
the bell you gotta ring the bell get the
notifications
you get all the new videos that come out
on this channel you go over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
what do you do you type in the michael
knowles show
subscribe
maybe leave a five star review you'll
get totally uncensored content too hot
for youtube you'll get it all over there
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]